auf jeden fall heute sehen wir hier
einen dispenser mit einer seltsamen
komischen botschafter nehmen dass hier
drin die op waffe ist und dort ist schon
rein und gucken was da versteckt so
sechs kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video zu erstmal danke danke
danke für die tolle resonanz auf das
gestrige videos hat mir richtig gut
gefallen hat mich richtig gefreut
echt interessante und rührende
geschichten hier denn die kommentare
geschildert das war super aber heute
zeige ich euch mal was was ich noch nie
gezeigt haben job liegt zwar ein secret
dafür müssen wir aber in staff match der
map in osteuropa zweisitzer rechts wir
müssen die map in europa zwei spielen
und ihr seht auf wie viele prämien
spieler dieser runde sind hier seit
einer halben stunde lobby darauf dass in
osteuropa kommt jetzt ist gekommen und
ich würde sagen wir sehen uns im
deathmatch dann zeige ich euch mal was
ich meine
ach ja leute bestehe jetzt kurzum der
von euch eine sache wo ich noch sagen
und zwar wir schauen wir kurz freuen ist
es rein
ich habe eiskalt 1200 games gespielt und
bis heute wusste ich von diesem komplex
sieg wird einfach nichts ist eine op
waffe die davon steckt das auf dieses
match arena und ich denke mal wenn ich
nach 1000 spielen und ich wusste dass
sie da ist dann ist es ein ganz schön
heißer tipp vielleicht auch für die
leute die noch nicht eingespielt haben
deswegen jetzt endgültig schauen wir mal
im deathmatch nach wo sich die op waffe
versteckt drei tage später okay leute
deathmatch ist erreicht wir haben hier
schön die vorrüstung die wir nach es
regel aber natürlich mit dem chain am
rocken mit dem claim rocken
wir haben direkten gegner hinter uns das
ist übrigens der map aber hier angeblich
brave der diesem wetter baut hatte er
zumindest
ich hoffe mal sagt die wahrheit und
jetzt und jetzt und jetzt du wirst doch
nicht du wirst doch nicht als ob er das
macht nein das macht er nicht
das macht er nicht er will er mich vor
uns ist holen da wir vor uns liegen ja
ihr seht ihr das wort für diese website
als ob er mit mir in der runde ist und
mir einfach dass sie gut vor der nase
wegschnappt aber ich glaube er möchte
einfach mit dabei sein welches mit
seiner eigenen website ist fair hat sie
auch selbst gebaut und zwar gehen wir
hier unten rein hat ihr das gesehen
wir gehen noch mal hoch also wir sind
hier ja und von dieser stelle aus obst
oder sogar einer wir müssen die ganzen
leute weg hatten von dieser stelle aus
geht man hier unten rein also unter
diesen bogen direkt runter sich in
idealer weise in der zeit nicht
angreifen lassen so zac um hier rein
sieht alles sehr dunklen sehr special
aus danke übrigens an herr réti der mit
diesem tipp glaube ich gehe jeden hat
der sommer bei mir auf dem ts dankeschön
ich glaube es war sehr rege
dann kann dich und da gehen wir hier
rein hier rein fallen jetzt hier nicht
in die lava vorsichtig sein
sehr vorsichtig so da muss man jetzt
echt vorsichtig sein
ganz schön heiß da unten jetzt so das
kopfball wieder abbauen und das abbauen
und laura grave sich umgebracht erst gar
nicht mehr drin
auf jeden fall leute sehen wir hier
einen dispenser mit einer seltsamen
komischen botschaft annehmen
das steht hier ausgezeichnet 332 gx eine
fucking kette warum seine kette diesem
schild 73 wjd ausrufzeichen hkd
dollar ich glaube was es sagen will ist
dass hier drinnen die op waffe ist und
jetzt schauen wir rein und gucken was
sich da versteckt ich wo ich wusste bis
dato auch nicht wie schon jetzt rein
alles klar und es ist ein internet der
bogen namens mp5 mit stärke 1 das ist
ziemlich heiß und diesen bogen kann man
in jeder runde holen
aber man muss einfach nur untergehen
dieser runde auf ein europa 2 und dieses
geheimversteck hier und sich den den
bogen schnappen er zu sein nur noch
zurückkommen
ohne die lauer zu fallen was gar nicht
so easy ist weiß ihr bisschen stück
gebautes ehrlich gesagt
aber krämer hin notfalls kann man sich
immer noch unten löschen
jetzt geht es zurück dass es so eine
unterwasser höhle der seiner mit der wut
soll gefälscht um ein schöner machen wir
ja ein bisschen trubel ist lag bisschen
habe ich gefühlt und war dann find fight
unsere unsere mp5 hat einen schuss
unsere mp5 war zumindest schon mal einen
schuss alles klar
okay das geht mir das ist ein gegner der
krieg die 1590 und mit der mp 5 nicht
getroffen aber werden tatsächlich runde
gewonnen wenn auch durch die mitte aber
durch die mitte gewinnen zählt nicht
aber jetzt wisst ihr wo dieser oper ist
mir schreiben an die reihen der chat
plan ist wieder abgelaufen den ich für
das hater video bekommen habe die
dankeschön dafür und ihr habt das was
vom heutigen video
wollt ihr noch mehr von solchen jumping
tipps haben dann schreibt das unbedingt
morgen in die kommentare rein dann werde
ich mal beim einer community in allen
möglichen jump it provider sammle nach
tipps können mindestens einen weiteren
durch bestimmt auch interessiert sind
ihr euch gerne zeigen also wenn ihr
sowas cool findet am klick-tipps gezeigt
dann schreibt uns in die kommentare und
lassen sagt er
da gibt's fortsetzung bis zum nächsten
video so oder so haut rein macht gut und